beginning tomorrow federal agents will
begin a nationwide effort to arrest
immigrants who have been issued final
deportation orders the raids will be
targeted in ten major cities and will
focus mainly on Central American
families that cross the US border with
Mexico President Trump says the
crackdown is meant to remove criminals
from the country but the leaders in some
of these cities are pushing back against
the effort Laura Podesta is here with
more Laura good morning good morning
that includes the mayor here in New York
City along with the supervisor of Los
Angeles County the mayor of San
Francisco as well as the Governor of
California
now this sweep is similar in scope to
those carried out by Immigration and
Customs Enforcement or ice since 2003
but this one is different because it's
part of president Trump's plan to
eventually deport millions of people
here illegally they're going to take
people out and they're going to bring
them back to their countries or they're
going to take criminals out put them in
prison or put them in prison in the
countries they came from
president Trump describing how he
envisions ice agents will carry out the
nationwide deportation action set to
begin tomorrow administration officials
say the operation is targeting about
2,000 people and in many cases entire
families previous crackdowns of the same
size have resulted in an arrest rate of
about 10% but as immigration enforcement
has become a central focus of the Trump
administration it's creating a pushback
in some communities with large
immigration populations New York City
Mayor and presidential candidate Bill de
Blasio has said the city will not help
ice in making arrests San Francisco
mayor London breed reminded residents of
her city of their rights
everyone is guaranteed certain rights
under the Constitution whether they are
in this country illegally or not
California governor Gavin Newsom did the
same on Twitter when we talk about
knowing your rights know about snow
Puerta now without a warrant you don't
have to open the door some local law
enforcement officers say the raids could
impact more than just illegal immigrants
and their families and the fear alone
and there's been studies have shown that
that fear goes all the way to
US citizens already that presence of ice
so that impact is very very damaging
Friday night dozens of protests were
held nationwide against both the
proposed raids and the conditions at
facilities where immigrants are being
detained hundreds gathered at this one
outside the White House including
undocumented immigrant Harrison
Quintero's I feel like scare everyday I
don't know what to do but I know that
with my community I'm in strength and I
actually feel stronger I feel safe with
my community I feel protected by my
community
Washington DC is another city that has
said it won't be assisting ice in making
arrests also to leading hotel chains
Marriott and choice owners of Comfort
Inn sleepin and Econo Lodge among others
have said they do not want ice to use
their hotels to hold any detainees Dana
more very interesting thank you very
much we'll continue to watch